what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
hey guys before we get this video
started just want to let you all know
that myself and Vinnie over comic story
in and Natalie Zanna cool candy all over
at elgible monster
we've relaunched that channel so if you
guys want to see us play video games and
hang out and you know get shot with nerf
guns and all kinds of good stuff to make
sure you guys go check that out make
sure you so check out the videos a whole
nine yards but anyway so getting into
this ah man dude the flash god man the
flash is the best thing come out of DC
rebirth and there's no arguing that
point there this this story man this is
so good absolutely love the flash but
with the whole lot the whole concept of
eobard thawne the reverse-flash this
story is really going to serve two
purposes the first is to you know
reshuffle his origin a little bit and
shed some light on the you know DC
rebirth landscape with regards to the
reverse flash and the second is that
it's actually going to make him I think
more tragic I think this origin story
that we get here is better than his
original origin now for those people who
were new to the flash mythos who were
new to my channel have never you know
seen videos like this before I want to
talk to these guys for a second so if
you've been around for a little while
bear with me I want to talk to the new
guys for a second so Ivar Thawne is
effectively like the arch enemy of the
flash Barry Allen I mean they are mortal
enemies
the idea is that eobard thawne draws on
something called the negative Speed
Force and the way this works is that for
the most part it's almost identical to
the Speed Force in a sense that it
allows you know eobard thawne to run
super fast and he has regenerative
healing and he can run into other
dimensions that he can run through time
and so on and so forth the difference
here is that the negative Speed Force is
a cancerous source in the sense that it
basically exists to effectively eat away
at the Speed Force and to corrupt those
individuals who tap into the Speed Force
and so the ultimate goal of eobard
thawne is of course to kill Barry Allen
you know two more let's make his life a
living hell but to also corrupt him by
virtue of corrupting the Speed Force
which means that it would it would
spread like if you dropped ink into a
jar of water you know that inks going to
spread all over the plates the negative
Speed Force does the exact same thing
but with regards to the history between
the two in new 52 when DC relaunched
everything in 2011
eobard thawne got a brand new origin and
a lot of people didn't like it a lot of
people were really upset about it
because they prefer the original flash
rebirth story back before the new 52 you
weren't shine some light on his origin
talked about how he had basically
instigated all the events of Barry
Allen's life that led to him to becoming
the flash it really shined a lot of
light on eobard thawne in terms of what
he was and why he functioned and so on
and so forth
what DC did with regards to DC rebirth
is they came back and they basically
fixed all that in the same way that
Wally West had appeared and basically
talked to Barry Allen and woke him up to
the way that things are supposed to be
the impact of flashpoint the idea that
presumably somebody out there who we
know to be dr. Manhattan messed with
everybody's memories and all that kind
of good stuff
during the events of DC rebirth the
exact same thing happened at eobard
thawne and the result was that he
basically woke up to everything that
existed before the new 52 during the new
52 up to the current moment and that's
one of the reasons why his actions
during the button set him in motion of
trying to find out who had was that
messed with everybody's memories because
he'd been woken up to the fact that
someone out there was so powerful they
could effectively reshape the entirety
of the universe on a whim and so it was
a pretty huge thing that really gets us
caught up to the current moment I mean
the only thing would happen before this
story was a eobard thawne had basically
you know returned hydras presumed death
during the events of the button he had
beat the heck out of new 52 Wally West
and then kidnapped iris West
took her to the future knowing Barry
Allen would follow and that's exactly
what happens here Barry Allen really
just kind of like pops up in the 25th
century now the funny thing about this
is remember eobard thawne originates
from the 25th century and this is where
the new origin story begins to come into
play from the perspective of Barry Allen
this initial origin is given to us in
the form that he shows up and he meets a
young a abarth on who basically sees
himself as someone that's going to be
like the flash eobard thawne idolizes
Barry Allen now what will happen here in
a little while is will actually get the
eobard thawne perspective of this which
will give us even more information but
the idea here is that with Barry Allen
being met by what appears to be his
biggest fan he effectively takes eobard
thawne under his wing and the idea is
that he starts training him to become
the flash using his powers in a way
disrespective making him a super hero
for the 25th century which is everything
that a of our Thawne could ever hope for
the problem with this is that somewhere
along the line eobard thawne fell to
being a bad guy now we're not explicitly
told what any one particular action was
instead we're basically given this idea
that eobard thawne became more and more
extreme in the sense
he was hurting people more than he
needed to in order to basically keep
them from committing crimes now of
course as we know with the flash Barry
Allen he has powers he could kill
virtually anybody that he came across so
long as they're not like Superman or
somebody like that but he always holds
back because he recognizes that the goal
is to basically imprison and
rehabilitate not to kill and so what
ends up happening here is that eobard
thawne basically returns later on as the
reverse-flash as we know him now this is
a little 2 page explanation given to us
by Barry Allen and this for the most
part is what we already know what a of
our Thawne is going to do and he's going
to come back and give us the whole
backstory and tell us how things really
are and that's where things get really
cool but Barry Allen basically showing
up in the 25th century instead of it
being this Age of Enlightenment where
things are so much better
instead he basically comes across as
very dark future where superheroes are
effectively feared or at least the
flourish is essentially feared as
opposed to being worshipped now what
this does is it leads him to retreat to
the flash Museum ultimately locating
iris West whereby eobard thawne makes
his presence known and that's kind of
the crazy thing here is because there's
always been this emblem of the flash
museum when it came to eobard thawne
that's one of the things about his
original origin oh really that the most
popular origin that people know during
the story the return of Barry Allen in
the 1990s I think it was maybe the 1980s
but during that story it was the idea
that eobard thawne was obsessed with
Barry Allen see it visited the flash
Museum time and time again and so it's a
well-established fact that in the 25th
century there's a museum dedicated to
Barry Allen and its exploits at the
flash but what is it happening here
the eobard thawne gives us this back
aspect and what we end up finding out is
that eobard thawne as a kid had lost his
parents in some kind of tragic accident
what it is isn't really relevant but the
idea here is that he basically became
obsessed with the flash Barry Allen we
had nobody else to look up to and so of
course darling his costume dressing up
as the flash giving himself the same
powers led to Barry Allen's appearance
and the two of them becoming teammates
now a very significant moment here comes
between the two of them and it's
actually really really cool because they
have this sort of heartfelt discussion
with the idea that they can move so fast
they can achieve so many things they can
do so much with their life that time is
almost meaningless for them because they
can run back and forth through time they
can do all manner of different things
and time is really more of a tool as
opposed to a limitation but with
discussion between the two of them
it's Barry Allen effectively saying that
every second is a gift in any moment
they could effectively be killed now
this also coincides with the idea eobard
thawne becoming a bad guy but following
his defeat he had basically gone through
this kind of rehabilitation process and
that's what makes it so tragic is
because it doesn't look like he's
putting on a sham it doesn't look like
he was putting on a show he was going
through the motions of being a good guy
yadda yadda yadda that he actually was
trying to rehabilitate himself that he
was trying to be a hero he was trying to
live up to the mantle of Barry Allen as
a hero as opposed to just a guy out
there who's going to demotions and will
one day be the one to beat Barry Allen
and so what ended up happening is of
course he donned the cosmic treadmill
the device was basically used to travel
back and forth through time or to break
dimensional barriers and he actually
donned this yellow costume now the whole
idea behind the yellow costume in terms
of this origin is cool because in
previous stories it was designed to
basically show like yeah I'm the
antithesis of Barry Allen Iran I'm the
opposite of the flash on his mortal
enemy and all that kind of a thing and
this story he donned the yellow costume
because it's what all of Flash's
partners use because you remember when
the pre new 52 when the classic Wally
West was Kid Flash and he was the
sidekick of Barry Allen he wore yellow
eobard thawne basically modeled himself
after the sidekicks of Barry Allen
because he saw himself as a sidekick of
Barry Allen and that's what was so cool
because traveling into the past and
seeing Barry and then seeing Barry speak
with classic Wally West and then very
giving classic Wally was watch and
saying every second as a guest did it
betrays everything that eobard thawne
stood for it and that's what makes this
so cool and so tragic because in the
most popular origin from the return of
very Alan back you know during the the
Mark Waid days on the flash the origin
story of eobard thawne was pretty
straightforward he was a guy who was
obsessed with Barry Allen he made
himself look like Barry he gave himself
the same powers he travelled into the
past he came across a museum where he
realized that he was destined to become
the Flash's greatest enemy he had a
psychological break and became a bad guy
the whole idea with this origin is it
makes it far more tragic he saw himself
as a legitimate friend and a legitimate
sidekick of Barry Allen and going back
in time and seeing this moment shared or
at least the moment that he thought he
shared with Barry being shared with the
classic Wally West suddenly meant that
eobard thawne was not important he was
not significant he was just a guy that
very met somewhere and Barry didn't
think any
via Bart's on but eobard thawne thought
everything about Barry Allen as so again
it's this beautiful moment because now
efr Thawne had so much motivation I mean
that's one of the things that always
made him cool he was the guy that would
keep coming back over and over and over
again he was stronger he was faster than
Barry but in terms of the tragic element
of his character this I think does an
amazing job of bringing that into
fruition and so of course effectively
toppling very Allen one of the things
that very hints at is the notion of
eobard thawne killing iris West but the
funny thing about this is that evar
Thawne says look I could kill you but
there's no fun in that I mean what what
good would it do to kill you you
wouldn't suffer it would be too easy
it'd be too quick I'm going to make you
suffer by torturing everybody around you
and the first thing that he does is
reveal the identity of Barry Allen to
iris West and so again this is cool
because now iris knows exactly who he is
not only that is basically this notion
that iris West is confronted with the
idea that Barry Allen's been lying to
her the entire time now the cool thing
about this too is that eobard thawne
also takes them on this sort of journey
basically showing them the failures of
Barry Allen's showing him a future where
Barry Allen and iris West have kids and
their kids grow up to become villains
and the reason for this is because of
the fact that when it comes to the
decision of Barry Allen or the flash the
flash always wins out Barry Allen's in
the middle of a date with somebody and
he has to whisk off with the Justice
League because he's a flashed this
concept according to eobard thawne
extends to everything else very Alan
never makes time for those that he cares
about he's always off being the flash
he's always off being a superhero the
whole of humanity takes precedent over
his family which some would say makes
sense others would say that's a failing
but the idea here is it extends to his
family itself and simply sank that when
your kids were taking their first steps
when Barry Allen's kids were speaking
for the first time when they had their
recitals when they had their plays he
was off being the flash and so he
basically had children who grew up to
resent him because he never played a
role in their life and this is huge
because this cannot help but impact iris
West
Barry Allen tries to blow it off and say
all of our zombie any of our authorities
a bad guy look for iris West it's but
maybe there's some truth to that like
you've been lying to me this entire time
because you've been trying to protect me
but at what point do you stop and say
maybe I shouldn't protect them maybe I
should just be there for them and that
whole idea that iris West is wrestling
with a moment because again on one side
she says look okay I understand that if
people if you people knew that I knew
who you were they would come after me
they would try to attack me they would
kill me torture me for information
whatever the case may have been but from
the perspective of iris West in truth
that's the risk she's willing to take
and we know just by virtue of the flash
stories before the new 52
that was very having his identity
exposed to Iris at the end of the day it
still benefits them because she's more
of an emotional support character for
him than anything else when he feels
like he can't go on iris West
has his back and he keeps on keeping on
and so again what is up happening here
is eobard thawne gives them a choice he
says look I will give you an opportunity
either you can continue on this path
that you're on or I can take you to a
place where you will never hurt anybody
else and you'll never be able to lie to
anybody else now of course theory
doesn't do this willy-nilly the bargain
that's more or less struck is that
eobard thawne will never harm iris west
now this is kind of uncharacteristic of
Barry I mean with eobard thawne Barry
having full memory about eobard is all
history the whole nine yards any of our
Thawne being who he is there's no reason
for Barry Allen to trust absolutely none
but for the most part very actually goes
with it the result is that eobard thawne
throws them into the negative Speed
Force now remember this is designed to
be a prison as much as it is a way for a
of our Thawne to corrupt Barry Allen
because the goal of a bar is to make
Barry Allen basically his equal or
somebody they can fight alongside him
somebody that'll be corrupted by the
negative Speed Force and will stop being
an enemy and effectively become an ally
the problem with this is that we're a
abarth on returns and tries to kill iris
West very emerges just in the nick of
time as the negative flash is like the
reverse flash I guess of himself it
looks really cool the way his character
is where the way his character is done
but if anything about this is that he's
basically imbued with the negative Speed
Force this is what Barry Allen would
look like if you were corrupted by the
negative Speed Force the difference here
is that he still has control of his
faculties he's still very much residing
you know with his love for iris West and
so on and so forth now of course this
leads directly to a fight between the
two of them that spans all the like the
entire whole of the world's history it
starts from the very beginning of time
all the way into the very distant future
remember this is the kind of thing that
we're dealing with when it comes to
eobard thawne and Barry
now fighting they can stretch across all
time and space it was really kind of a
cool moment to see here because
ultimately Barry Allen gets the upper
hand on eobard thawne when he stripped
some of its own speed and this is
designed to happen for a couple of
reasons the first is because it just
gives us an indication of a new kind of
powers at Barry Allen will have the
second is because it shows the hubris
and the arrogance of eobard thawne to
believe that he had the upper hand on
Barry without realizing what it is that
Barry was able to do with the negative
Speed Force and so of course disturbing
eobard thawne of his abilities you know
eobard is just a guy I mean he's just a
dude who's there somewhere now of course
going to try to attack iris West
ultimately she ends up this kind of you
know incinerating eobard thawne in his
entirety but he'll always make a return
but what this story does is it shifts
over to the relationship between Barry
and iris because at this point now iris
is in a tough spot what she has to do
was come to grips with the fact that
Barry has routinely lied to her and
regardless of what his motivation is in
the end it was a lie now the funny thing
about this and this is what makes us so
interesting is again she could have been
a support for Barry Allen had Barry gone
to her and said hey look I have to
reveal this to you because now I'm
running around with your nephew I have
to tell you that I'm the flash they
would have sorted it out together they
would have got it figured out together
Barry Allen lying to Iris West and not
telling her that he's the flash
indicates one major thing and it's that
he does not trust her with that
information regardless of how he
perceives it it's totally irrelevant
here's what people think is real and
there's what is real and that's the
nature of it it's not what Barry it's
not how Barry Allen thinks iris West
will perceive it it's how iris West
actually perceives it and she sees it as
though he does not trust her and so
again that's why the whole situation
becomes this very bitter moment between
the two of them because or they should
be friends where iris West says what
else are you aligned to me and he thinks
about telling her that the classic wally
west is back you know when he thinks
about revealing this information to her
although we can't because classic wally
west asked him not to in the end he has
to reconcile this with the fact that for
the most part
eobard thawne ultimately won that the
people that Barry Allen cares about
don't trust him anymore
iris West doesn't trust him the new 52
Wally West still doesn't trust Barry
Allen because Barry Allen lied to him
about his identity if he will - Barry
Allen cares about are starting to walk
away one by one and so the ultimate goal
of eobard thawne came to
and in the sense that he costs Barry
Allen the things that he loves the most
but we're not being said guys if you are
new here to come us explain make sure
you guys hit the soft button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you